it's official bado O'Rourke is running
for president baby the definitely white
possibly straight arguably male failed
senatorial candidate has brought a smile
to the face of every fawning mainstream
media reporter in the country the only
question that remains is whether even
one person outside of NBC headquarters
actually cares then are Democrats
signaling a willingness to moderate
possibly I'm not holding my breath but
there are some moves happening
Republicans block president Trump's
emergency declaration Gavin Newsom
governor of california blocks the death
penalty and finally the mailbag I'm
Michael Nolan this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
the moment we were all waiting for
finally finally a completely
unaccompanied and failed senatorial
candidate is running and he's really
weird yes finally here's this is the
bridge to the future we will get to his
announcement we'll get to his strategy
we'll get to the reaction we'll get to
whether or not this signals that the
Democrats are willing to moderate but
first let's make a little money honey
with pro talis there are days when I get
home and I can't wait to get my shoes
off because my feet are so sore from my
busy day I know some of you have those
days too when I travel I always end up
walking around a lot more than I do when
I'm home it can make my feet even my
whole body ache maybe you've noticed
that most people are unaware knee hip
back even upper body muscle tightness
and other issues can stem from improper
alignment that all begins in the foot
right there at the ankle this is true
for more than 80% of people Pro talus
insoles bridge the gap between custom
orthotics and over-the-counter cushioned
inserts they have over 1 million happy
customers and a 97% success rate Pro
talus and soles create a better
connection between your ankle and the
rest of your body and help with reduced
pain increased comfort better movement
elevated stamina and higher performance
Pro talus has over 100,000 positive
reviews they've been shown to provide
relief from foot knee hip back pain
including neuropathy plantar fasciitis
that seems like a bad word neuromas and
many more this week my listeners can
save $30 on every pair of Pro talus
insoles at PR o tal us.com when entry
podcast 30 the number 30 at check out
shipping is free if you buy two or more
pairs they'll upgrade you to free
expedited shipping kiev pro talus
insoles a try and experience the
difference more comfort more energy more
life they have a 90 day money-back
hassle-free guarantee you have nothing
to lose except the pain check these out
they are a game changer PR OT al us.com
promo code podcast 30 save $30 on every
pair of pro talus insoles finally bado
O'Rourke is running for president we all
knew he was gonna do it he's been
angling to do it ever since he failed to
beat Ted Cruz for the Texas Senate race
then he
on his little weird adventure where he
was posting these bizarre diary entries
that was like a seventh grader reading
Jack Kerouac or Holden Caulfield or
something it did it was not a good look
here I'll just let you see it
unvarnished his announcement video then
we can react to how he looks how he
launches and what his strategy is gonna
be for 2020 Amy and I are happy to share
with you that I'm running to serve you
as the next president of the United
States of America this is a defining
moment of truth for this country and for
every single one of us the challenges
that we face right now the
interconnected crises in our economy our
democracy and our climate have never
been greater and they will either
consume us or they will afford us the
greatest opportunity to unleash the
genius of the United States of America
in other words this moment of peril
produces perhaps the greatest moment of
promise for this country and for
everyone inside of it that's right
that's why bado
that's why bado is running bado is
running for president he's gonna throw
his arms up in the air and he's gonna do
the monkey and he's got I don't know
what he's gonna do
it's a very we awkward physicality that
this man has I have to admit I don't
like him I don't I'm going to admit that
this is largely subconscious this is not
a precisely rational dislike I I don't
think I've ever had a more viscerally
negative reaction to a politician in my
life than this guy regardless of what
they say regardless of what they propose
just the way they look and move and talk
I don't like him I don't trust him
he is unctuous he is weak he looks like
a little slick that feminist man in
college who's like the creepiest guy
that you've ever seen that's made óäåor
work I I don't understand I guess this
is probably why the mainstream media
liked him so much uh but this is the
problem Harvey Mansfield wrote this book
on manliness called manliness and he
writes in that that men just naturally
really don't like effeminate men and you
can sort of come over this this is not
to say gay men this is not
say even gender-confused men there's a
difference between being effeminate as a
man and wearing a dress I guess bata or
work does both so it's a little
confusing is bata O'Rourke when he was
in some rock band in his 20s he would
actually wear a dress but what I mean by
effeminate is just his just his
mannerisms he's just so he's just so
earnest he's just so saccharine
he's just so scripted he's just so I'm
just at my man ice guy hmm hey c'mere
let stole your boyfriend sounds so mean
come here let's talk about you know I
just this is the but and by the way this
matters because facts don't care about
your feelings but politics exclusively
cares about your feelings so it doesn't
really matter what he's proposing people
are gonna get a first impression people
are going to react to him in this way
and I don't think that any
self-respecting man in the entire
country could look at this guy and think
this is a good candidate I just don't
see it you've what is the campaign gonna
be if this 30 seconds is any indication
it's going to be saccharine it's going
to be scripted and it's going to try to
be centrist that's gonna be beta it's
all this is the earnest this is why he's
doing these crazy arm gestures she's
trying to say I'm really earnest come on
guys come on get let's get together guys
come on it's so annoying also it's very
scripted he's reading off the prompter
for this which is fine reading off the
prompter is no big deal but he's reading
off the prompter in what should be an
impromptu announcement he's on his couch
with his wife it's 2019 so in 2019
authenticity impromptu off-script is way
better it just plays better HD video it
just plays better I mean this is why
beta was live-streaming him getting his
teeth cleaned a few months ago this is
why aoc live streams for cooking dinner
no script it just seems more authentic
this seems disingenuous he's trying to
appeal to centrist so he's this kind of
I don't know manufactured product he's
he's this kind of he's
built by the mainstream media but he's
trying to appeal to centrist he's trying
to appeal to the extreme left he's
trying to appeal to everybody and it
just just doesn't seem quite genuine I
mean despite all of the glowing media
coverage beta or Rourke is making this
claim that he is going to have a
grassroots campaign and I invite you to
join us in a kickoff for this campaign
but even if you cannot be here on March
30th I still want your help
organizing where you live bringing in
friends and family and neighbors to the
greatest grassroots campaign this
country has ever seen
the greatest grassroot the greatest
grassroots campaign this country has
ever seen was probably Trump 2016 that
was genuinely grassroots he had the
entire party establishment the entire
conservative movement capital C capital
M and the entire media against him he
had everybody against him it was only
people who liked him that's what
grassroots is he didn't raise any money
from other people really was self-funded
this is not grassroots I mean this the
mainstream media have been fawning over
this guy since he started running for
Senate in Texas and he didn't even win
and then they kept saying well if he
doesn't win he'll still win and vanity
fair' is this beautiful cover of him
this is how the Today Show The Today
Show is not not the new media not a
grass roots rally not this is that the
Today Show on NBC breaks the news
they're so excited breaking news it's
official the high profile Democrat
announcing his presidential bid this
morning's the big name in the Democratic
Party making his White House run
official this morning so what's with all
the buzz behind federal awards two
months of hinting at a presidential run
in 2020 former Democratic congressman
beto award just made it official he is
in beto O'Rourke's announcement that
he's entering the 2020 race will shake
up the Democratic primary
Beto O'Rourke making it official the
former Texas congressman announcing he's
running for president
O'Rourke saying the interconnected
crises of the economy the climate and
the nation's democracy have never been
greater
the latest hint O'Rourke was ready to
run coming in a glossy Vanity Fair
spread overnight
captured by celebrity photographer Annie
Leibovitz O'Rourke saying I'm just born
to do this grassroots grassroots I don't
I don't know that one single person who
is not in the mainstream media is
excited that they do or work is running
but all of the media are doing it I mean
Vanity Fair can be pretty brutal they
did a profile on they've done a couple
profiles on us actually and they did one
on all these people in in politics and
government the media and all of them all
the Democrats have these beautiful
photos and then they did a photo of Ben
which is I don't know how they even got
this look Ben never has this look on his
face but it's this it's not a good look
and they just use the worst possible
photo they could find but then for bado
O'Rourke oh he's standing in Texas he's
got his blue jeans nice blue shirt
he's casual but he's not too casual he's
ready to work I'm in and I was born for
this
this is the grassroots of beta or work
now obviously that's ridiculous he's
gonna have to eventually appeal to
voters how's he going to appeal to
voters what we see from this video is
that he's trying to position himself as
a centrist look he still got his
left-wing orthodoxy and he still talked
about the climate he's still making this
a key aspect of his campaign because it
is not possible to run in this Democrat
primary without talking about the
climate the climate is the left-wing
religion now the climate is especially
in a time when there are no real
tangible issues the economy is doing
very well we have a relative peace we
have record high employment you can't
talk about any tangible issue so it's
the climate you're talking about
essentially a religious issue for the
left so he gets that in there but he's
trying to appeal to all Americans he's
talking about for farmers bringing
everybody together he's talking about
how we need to help the American worker
dignified work all this sort of stuff
he's so centrist in this video he even
mimics Ronald Reagan I think a lot of
people didn't quite pick up on this but
he is paraphrasing Reagan very closely I
want to leave you with this
the only way for us to live up to the
promise of America is to give it our all
and to give it for all of us we are
truly now more than ever the last great
hope of Earth at this moment of maximum
peril and maximum potential
let's show ourselves and those who will
succeed us in this great country just
who we are and what we can do okay so
you hear this we're the last great hope
of Earth this is we've got to show them
we've got it so from Ronald Reagan's
probably most famous speech a time for
choosing he is taking this line from
Ronald Reagan and he's changing it just
a little bit here's Reagan Winston
Churchill said the destiny of man is not
measured by material computations when
great forces around the move in the
world we learn where spirits not animals
and he said there's something going on
in time and space and beyond time and
space which whether we like it or not
spells duty you and I have a rendezvous
with destiny
will preserve for our children this the
last best hope of man on earth or will
sentence them to take the last step into
a thousand years of darkness so he this
is intentional by the way I mean this
speech from Ronald Reagan is one of the
most famous American political speeches
ever that line is one of the most famous
American political lines ever invade
o'rourke is using that he wants to have
that Reaganesque appeal but he changes
it a little bit you hear Ronald Reagan
says that the United States is the last
best hope of man on earth of man on
earth what is beta or work say says this
is the last great hope of Earth it's a
subtle distinction but what Ronald
Reagan is doing is putting man at the
center of politics you say politics is
about men this is a normal ordering of
things he looks up to Providence then we
have politics the affairs of men and men
have dominion and stewardship over the
earth over creation we need we need to
be stewards for us what bait or work
does this flips it in the way that the
environmentalist Left flips it where he
says we're the last hope of Earth so
it's the earth that we are serving not
the men on earth not all the men who
long for freedom behind the Iron Curtain
not all the men who long for a world
order who long for global peace and
prosperity no no the earth itself the
rocks and the trees and the deer and the
rabbits that is the environmentalist
leftist aspect of it but it's that same
Reagan it's it's sort of the difference
between the traditional order of things
the the order of things that tells us
that we are not just animals were not
just flesh we are different than the
animals we have a spiritual dimension
Ronald Reagan quotes Churchill he says
when great forces are on the move in the
world we learn were spirits not animals
what beta or Roarke is talking is in
material terms it's just the earth it's
the dirt it's the farmers
it's the Biss it's just all material
it's all stuff there's no spiritual
component to it because the left lacks a
spiritual component to it now he's
running his Obama I mean that's gonna be
the the bado move he's gonna run his
Obama and see if that can work a second
time the trouble is he's not Obama
Barack Obama was much better much more
likable than bado of work the trouble
with beta will work is that he actually
is a beta male I don't I'm saying that
sort of to joke about him but I mean
that just as a pure observation he's not
a manly man he wore dresses with a
serious face in his twenties he he's
always dressing down he's always so I'm
a sensitive guy mmm yeah
and when he gets overly excited he loses
control of his emotions so his arm
instead of his arm sort of going this
you know this that just as a matter of
rhetoric and oratory his arm goes like
you just loses control of himself he
loses control of his voice of the volume
of his voice of the tone of his voice he
just is a beta male I don't know how
else to put it he's a wimp he's weak
Barack Obama at least in his campaigns
didn't come off that way Barack Obama
did project a strength a certain there's
no red America there's no blue America I
love you back I mean there was a real
confidence to Barack Obama I mean he
would go limp wristed when he was
talking to dictator
but actually on the campaign trail had a
real confidence that bado lacks all so
you can't just relive history you can't
be I mean this is what Republicans have
sort of tried and failed to do for 30
years you can't just run as Ronald
Reagan Ronald Reagan was very successful
Ronald Reagan was the best Ronald Reagan
ever and Ronald Reagan was a cool guy
you are not Ronald Reagan you can't run
as him you can't relive his career you
can't just have somebody else's career
you have to be you all of the American
presidents certainly all of the notable
ones have been are pretty original
Donald Trump certainly an American
original Barack Obama he's an American
original where else but in America could
that man become president george w bush
a very different man from his father
these guys they're they have their
distinct voice they have their distinct
agenda baito or work doesn't have that
he's just a politician he's just a guy
who was what was in the El Paso City
Council or something then he was in
Congress where he accomplished basically
nothing then he tried to run for Senate
and failed and then this is the issue
he's running for president and he tells
Vanity Fair I want to be in it man I'm
just born to be in it there's no draft
bado movement there was no draft Obama
movement these were guys who didn't need
any convincing they want to be in it
this is a very stark distinction from
the traditional statesman who
reluctantly goes and accepts power who
just is gonna serve the people and then
go back to his farm or something no this
is an ambitious guy who all he ever
wanted was political power so when he
says I want to run to serve you it just
doesn't you don't buy it now we see I
mean the fact that he's running as a
centrist tells us something about what
the campaign is going to look like
because I guess he's running as a
centrist now right now he actually said
he came and he said quote I'm a
capitalist I don't see how we're gonna
meet any of the fundamental challenges
that we have
a country without in part harnessing the
power of the market so he says I'm a
capitalist on the one hand then he's
talking to a bunch of reporters and he
says I'm in favor of the green New Deal
I think we only have 12 years before the
world is going to end
so it's this bizarre schizophrenic
Democrat primary one minute they're
super conservative super condemn sorry
they're not super conservative all one
minute they're super left-wing super
radical the next minute they're trying
to appear moderate and centrist but
they're gonna have to pick a side and
the more you flip-flop back and forth
the tougher chance you're gonna have of
convincing the voting public that you're
earnest that you actually stand for
something that you're not just a cynical
politician this raises the question are
the Democrats ultimately by the end of
2020 going to moderate or are they going
to go all the way to the left Elizabeth
Warren gives us a little hint into this
but I will say before we move on from
bado I do want to make one side point
his name's not bado
his name is robert Francis Roark if he
entered this race as Robert O'Rourke or
Bob O'Rourke nobody would be talking
about him he wouldn't get her Vanity
Fair profile he wouldn't be touted on
MSNBC he wouldn't none of those things
but because he adopted a Spanish name
because he's pretending to be a Hispanic
people love him and they treat him as
though he's Hispanic this is why words
really matter this is why the sound of
words matter is you can look at the most
Irish guy on the face of the earth and
you could hear that his name is Beto and
then you can say all right I guess he's
the Mexican guy Wow how inspiring how
great so this has led me I'm not running
for the Democrat nomination for
president I have no intention of doing
it even though everyone else in the
country is however just in case I want
to I've decided from now on I am
requesting than everybody exclusively
refer to me as Pedro Michael Pedro
Knowles or just Pedro is what I would
prefer just look at me
all of this Pedro Pedro it's I don't
know people have been calling me Pedro
for years Pedro and I that is the only
way
as intersectional identities victim
politics advances I think that's really
the only way that we're gonna be able to
have a say in our politics so I'm just
going to start it now if the whitest guy
in America can pretend to be a Mexican I
think I can do it too
Pedro Knowles now in the future we have
to change the name of the show to
Elizabeth Warren is showing us that
possibly the Democrats want to moderate
Nancy Pelosi - but first we the people
holsters oh yes we the people holsters
offers custom-made holsters all produced
in the USA they designed their own
holsters in-house means they don't use
any third-party molds for their holsters
instead they design every unique mold in
Las Vegas in order to best fit each and
every firearm perfectly they constantly
update designs adding new designs every
month which lets them stay up to date on
the newest models that come out we the
people holsters even have their own 3d
design team who measures every micro
millimeter of their guns to ensure the
perfect fit their unique and intuitive
clip design allows for you to easily
adjust both the canned and ride of your
holster so that it will fit comfortably
and securely at all times every holster
has adjustable retention which is
signaled with a click sound this lets
you know that your firearm is securely
in place if you want even more tension
you can just tighten one screw and
you're done custom printed designs
in-house thin blue line Constitution
camo American flag they are great they
started just 37 dollars a piece
every holster comes with a lifetime
guarantee every holster ships free
that's not the perfect fit send it back
for a refund
right now listeners of the michael dole
show can get go to we the people
holsters comm slash knowles KO wles
enter promo code knowles at checkout to
get $10 off their first holster that's
as low as 37 bucks and shipping is free
with an additional $10 off using my
promo code again We the People holsters
comm slash Knowles canna wles
promo code Knowles to check out for $10
off Elizabeth Warren of all people is
coming back as the voice of reason and
moderation in the Democrat Party I've
seen it all but between her between bado
between Nancy Pelosi perhaps it is the
case that AOC has peaked socialism has
peaked and the establishment Aryans are
coming back to take
their party how do you explain where you
are on the question of capitalism
socialism and where do they marry each
other so look I believe in markets I see
the benefits that markets can produce I
love the fact that there are zillion
people out there developing new apps or
starting new businesses or trying a
second life I think that's fabulous she
thinks that's fabulous she loves markets
she's a huge fan of markets what this
this woman was the farthest left voice
in the Democrat Party not five six years
ago now today all of a sudden she has
become the conservative I mean this is
the these are the two polls this is a
fight for the soul of the Democrat Party
I know that sounds like a contradiction
in terms the soul of the Democrat Party
but that's really what this is you've
got a OC and Bernie Sanders talking
about the virtues of breadlines
Bernie Sanders actually said bread lines
are a good thing because then people get
bread eventually maybe and then you've
got Elizabeth Warren of all people
defending markets this is an important
battle to be having it's sort of like
the iran-iraq war in the sense that I
hope they both lose I don't really care
who wins this because if the leftist
crazies win we're gonna have a much
easier time winning in the general
election in 2020 and if the centrists
win you've pushed off socialism through
the main vessel of socialism in America
which is the Democrat Party for at least
a little while longer who is going to
win I highly suspect that the socialists
are gonna win I do I know there are a
lot of polls out that show socialists
are not very popular as presidential
candidates or this or that I don't buy
that because you just are fighting this
inevitable tide is it's generations like
Millennials become the majority of
voters you're going to see that that
generation the majority of whom now
identify with socialism are going to be
pushing for those candidates and
especially when you have a polarizing
president like Donald
who fights back who triggers the left
who just drives them so crazy they are
gonna demand a fighter on their side
it's not gonna be Liz Warren I mean she
is done the Indian heritage fraud has
killed her campaign she is a dead woman
walking but for the other people who
were who were blowing in the wind Kamala
Harris one day she is a socialist the
next day she's a capitalist bado
O'Rourke one day he calls himself a
capitalist the next day he wants the
green New Deal to take over private
industry and Institute 80% taxes you're
going to see the people who fight the
people who get a little more extreme are
going to be the ones who have a bit of
help these are the ones who are going to
win actual grassroots support and not
just fake Vanity Fair support you know
Vanity Fair the mainstream media always
seemed to pick the worst candidates
they're always rooting for candidates
who just don't win you've seen this in
Republican and Democrat primaries I
think that's what's going on with bado I
think he's a whole lot of nothing
certain polls put him at the top of the
race along with Biden and Bernie Sanders
I think that's just a matter of name
recognition I think as other candidates
get more name recognition you're gonna
see them beat them down you're gonna see
this even in the debates this smooth
Obama bado I think he's gonna let his
emotions run away with him in debates
he's just not gonna look strong enough I
mean the probably the manliest candidate
in the race right now is Amy Klobuchar
and I assume that if bado starts going
off on his wimpy tangents has holden
caulfield stuff she's just gonna pull
the debate podium up and throw it at his
head on the stage so the question is can
he identify a campaign theme stop
playing the field stop trying to be
everything to everybody stop trying to
be a typical politician before it's too
late
Nancy Pelosi same thing Nancy Pelosi
came out the other day she said I'm not
for impeachment she said this is news
I'm gonna give you some news right now
because I haven't said this Danni press
person before since you asked I'm
thinking about this impeachment is so
divisive to the country that unless
there's something so compelling and
overwhelming and bipartisan
I
don't think we should go down that path
because it divides the country and he's
just not worth it
she's trying to moderate - she's
starting to think maybe the debt maybe
we shouldn't go down this socialism
train now she has different incentives
than the presidential candidates do
she's in Congress voters expect
different things of these guys but is
leading these two sides of the Democrat
Party to a fight to a brutal
confrontation that confrontation is
going to occur during the 2020 Democrat
primary get your popcorn it's going to
be a blast we've got a lot more to get
to we got to get to the mailbag first
it's almost time for our next episode of
the conversation on Wednesday March 20th
at 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific we're
gonna be changing things up with a live
book signing of Ben's new book the right
side of history for this episode only
you get to ask Ben questions if you have
purchased a copy of his book so what are
you waiting for I read the book when it
was still in draft form it's a very
important book as far as all these
popular books go about the culture but
this is by far the most important one
that's come out recently you got to
check it out so make sure to StayTuned
participate in Ben's live book signing
Wednesday March 20th 7 p.m. Eastern 4
p.m. Pacific on this special episode of
the conversation you go to daily wire
calm 10 bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me you get the end
replevin sure you have Ben Shapiro sure
you get the mount wall show your test
questions of the mailbag coming up you
get everything and you get the leftist
tears tumblr mm-hmm oh that's really
good that's that south-of-the-border el
paso baito edition make sure you get
yours before the Democrat 2020 primary
drowns you we'll be right back with the
mailbag in one second
first question from grant dear Michael
from the block what is your opinion on a
political science degree many people
seem to think that it's useless yes it
is then it was a Poli Sci major he says
the degree is totally useless and it is
however I would like to make this point
the problem with a Poli Sci degree is
not that it is just professionally
useless the liberal arts are supposed to
be professionally useless that is the
point of liberal arts they are not
supposed to train you for any particular
professional skill they're not supposed
to get you a job that is not that is
explicitly not with the liberal arts are
for and the liberal arts are still very
very important the liberal arts the word
liberal is the key to the liberal arts
the liberal arts exist to help us make
sense of our freedom to help us earn our
freedom to help us be free citizens when
the liberal arts go away free society
goes away it's as simple as that it's
how you learn about your civilization
that's how you learn about the ideas
that have shaped your civilization it's
how you learn about politics how you
learn about philosophy how you learn
about culture literature mathematics how
you learn about God the nature of
metaphysics and divinity it is hugely
important in in the traditional academic
structure there were the liberal arts
and the mechanical arts that's the
difference mechanical arts are
professionally useful liberal arts or to
help you understand your freedom so the
mechanical arts traditionally were
tailoring or weaving agriculture farming
if you go to farm school or a kotecha a
warfare or the military military
training trade today we would call that
a business degree cooking and
blacksmithing those are mechanical arts
those are training for jobs the liberal
arts on the other hand are grammar logic
rhetoric that was called the Trivium and
then arithmetic geometry music theory
and astronomy astronomy
that's the quadrivium the liberal arts
as we talk about them now and
a degree in English or a degree in
history as I have or a degree in
philosophy those are the liberal arts
whenever somebody tells you that your
liberal arts degree won't train you for
a job you should tell them yes of course
it won't that's the purpose of liberal
arts is not to train you for a job then
you can go get a hard skill after you
have gotten a liberal education to help
you understand your freedom
the problem with political science is
that it doesn't today really fulfill the
qualities of a liberal education because
if you were studying his political
philosophy for instance then okay you
could have a sense of the great thinkers
the great ideas that have shaped your
world why you think what you think why
we do what we do what our past is where
our future is going to look like
unfortunately today political science is
often just a lot of statistics and some
ideology mixed in and weak social
science that doesn't really fulfill that
so I think that's why it's particularly
useless but if you studied history or
philosophy or whatever that is good that
is a positive good is essential to a
free society that we have thriving
liberal education for some people not
everybody needs a liberal education just
some people the evidence of this is
Alexandria cassio Cortez she graduated
with a degree with honors in economics
she went to a school that cost $70,000 a
year to attend and she doesn't
understand basic economic concepts what
a bank does what a tax incentive is she
doesn't understand any of that
she's governing us she doesn't
understand our freedom she doesn't know
how to make sense of freedom and liberty
so if we have a whole Congress full of a
OCS we're not going to have that Liberty
very long we're not gonna have a free
society very long now once you get that
degree once you have that liberal
education then you can go to law school
which is basically a trade school you've
got a Business School a trade school
medical school a trade school you can
learn these hard skills to prepare you
for jobs but I break with so many
conservatives on this because I think so
many conservatives get this
totally wrong the liberal arts are
essential society is not just a bunch of
automatons making widgets there is a
dignified aspect to society - that is
civilization that is what gives us all
the things that we really care about in
this world which are metaphysical our
freedom our Joy's our loves that's how
we make sense of that if you lose that
you're gonna have a very crude rough
ugly society from Brett dear Michael
lately I've been texting a Christian
girl who went cold after we talked about
LGBT marriage I said that well I don't
recognize marriage outside of a man and
a woman the government should not be in
the business of marriage and try to make
it illegal
she believes gay marriage should just be
illegal who is right you're his bread
you're both wrong this is not a question
of being legal or illegal the question
is what is marriage this is why the left
gets us so wrong either they must
understand us or they're intentionally
slandering us because they say you don't
like gay people because you don't want
to redefine marriage when you're talking
about the point that we're making is
that marriage requires sexual difference
for all of human history marriage has
implied sexual difference if sexual
difference does not matter to marriage
than what is marriage if if marriage
which has always been the union of a
husband and wives at least one wife
sometimes more than one wife if marriage
is not that and it loses the sense of
creating family loses the sense of
sexual and spiritual and emotional
complementarity that loses the sense of
a household if it loses that sense and
it's just any loving association between
people of any sex then I don't know I
love my friends I love my male friends
what is that not a marriage well you
don't have sex
okay well people have sex with a lot of
other people that's not marriage what
what makes marriage now I think what
nice conservatives want to do is they
want to say well I oppose gay marriage
because it is a logical impossibility
but I all might have a lot of gays
fred's and I don't want them to think
that I'm some sort of bigot so let's
just get the government out of it do you
want to get the government out of the
definition of murder I don't know you
want to get the government out of the
definition of taxes do you want to get
the government out of the definition of
Township do you want I mean the
government has to recognize the meaning
of words and marriage is the fundamental
building block of society if the
government is out of the business of the
fundamental building block of society
then what does the government do what's
the purpose of the government I mean how
does the government relate to society
this is I think an essentially liberal
argument because what liberals of the
left want us to do is to treat society
as just a mass of random individuals all
atomized they have no relation to one
another they're fundamentally isolated
one one from another parent from child
husband from wife cousin from cousin
friend from friend there's no
relationships other than the individual
and the government but that isn't true
free society exists when we recognize
the family as the building block of
society and then the relationship of
families to other families the
relationship among civic institutions as
alexis de tocqueville points out the
relationship of the municipality to the
state in the state to the federal
government those are ways to check the
tyranny of one over powerful government
and a way for us to preserve our Liberty
and preserve our traditional Society the
government has to be involved one way or
the other especially when it comes to
who can adopt kids looking over the
welfare of kids so on and so forth the
government is gonna have to be involved
in some way and we can either pretend
that a word that has a very clear
meaning doesn't have a meaning or we can
acknowledge reality and say you don't
need to be mean to gay people to
acknowledge that marriage is marriage a
toaster is a toaster a toaster is not a
notecard
a cloud is not Honda these words have
meaning that's essentially the
disagreement that you and your your
girlfriend are having but you should
make it without any sort of animus I
mean
just make it on a very clear minded
illogical plane from Taylor Michael what
is the protocol for when a woman
attempts to open the door for a man in
public just one except does one refuse
to enter until the door closes and can
one open it for himself Thank You Taylor
here is the protocol when you are
walking up to a door open the door allow
the woman to go in if you walk up to the
door and the woman opens the door first
and points to you you point back to her
and you say oh please after you if she
at that point insists that you go first
then you go first
because a gentleman has to be gracious
you want to be chivalrous you always
want to give women the advantage always
want to give women a bit of grace but
you have to be gracious yourself the
purpose of a gentleman his first role is
to put other people at ease and so you
don't want to get into some match no you
go for it no you go first no you no you
no you you go first then you close it
now open it again no you offer you are
chivalrous and then if she insists you
relent so you do it from Sean a game
where the video game I guess where the
player is a rapist was I think rightly
and from valve a video game distributor
how do we decide when to ban something
like this or do we allow it to be
released and hope the market kills it it
seems like a pretty terrible video game
and it should be banned absolutely you
know it seems in this case the market
killed it because valve is is the market
it's not the government valve is going
in there and saying oh this is gonna be
bad for business we're not going to
allow this thing that's in terrible
taste to go out to the public so the
market worked in that respect where it
gets a little further down the line is
should the government be able to for
instance imprison particularly violent
pornographers for obscenity I think the
answer is obviously yes George W Bush
did this during his administration the
government absolutely has a right and
and really you have a right through your
government to ban obscenity obscene
things or not prefer not protected by
some perfect free speech that is not
what the First Amendment
that is not a way to have a particularly
civilized society we've had laws against
obscenity for a very long time in this
country in a lot of places you can't go
out and strip naked and run around naked
all over the streets
well isn't that your free speech no it's
obscene it's creating a public nuisance
and we can't only think of ourselves in
this narrow ideological way where the
left goes so wrong as the left is so
ideological but we cannot allow
ourselves to become ideological and make
an idol out of libertine ism or of
totally free markets without the
government regulating them at all no of
course not what sort of society do we
want to live in are we a people who are
self-governing a lot going to allow
ourselves to create and craft that
society certainly we should
traditionally in America we should and
to IDIA logs on either side shouldn't
tell us that we can okay that's our show
so much more to get to but alas we'll
have to wait until Monday have a good
weekend in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy Moore senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19